today we'll turn you our firestore
database into a full-text search engine
using algo leo
it's pointing something it's one of my
all-time favorite API s and I use it on
fire ship IO to power content discovery
features like Instant Search what you'll
build today is a pipeline with firebase
cloud functions that automatically
indexes your fire store data in algo Lea
and then we'll look at multiple
implementations to consume that data
from a customer facing app if you're new
here like and subscribe and check out
the full source code at fire ship IO so
let's start by answering the question of
when would you want to use a service
like algo Lea and keep in mind this
video is not sponsored so these are my
own personal opinions no SQL databases
like fire store are designed primarily
for fast reads and to scale seamlessly
but they can be relatively limited on
the types of queries you can make
especially if you need to search across
the entire text of a document or if you
need to filter by multiple properties
simultaneously and keep track of counts
of different properties algo Lea solves
all of these problems for you and more
it's really an ideal solution if you
have something like Amazon where you
have millions of products and you need
to sort these products and filter and
search them in many complex ways now
algo Lea starts off with a free tier but
one of the biggest complaints you might
hear is that it's expensive and I do
think that's a very valid complaint
especially if you have millions of
Records it jumps from free to $29 per
month up to $500 per month but as you'll
see in this video this is kind of a
situation where you get what you pay for
the first thing you want to do is sign
up for an algo Lea account and then it
will walk you through the process of
creating an index I'll go ahead and
create a new index called customers and
this will basically be a mirror of our
fire store data - any personally
identifiable information things like
email addresses and phone numbers are
not something that you want to keep in
the index you should keep in mind that
all this data will be exposed
client-side so you want to leave out any
information that would be considered
sensitive so now that we have this index
setup we have a whole bunch of different
ways to customize it I'll leave the
customization part up to you
but just know that there's a whole bunch
of cool things you can do like set these
searchable attributes tweak the ranking
and sorting algorithms setup typo
tolerance stop
and word proximity and a whole bunch of
other stuff and you could even generate
your own UI demo based on your own
underlying data and that means you can
get a solid mock-up of your search UI
before you write any front-end code so
now that we have this index created we
need a way to dynamically add data to it
and we want to add data to the index
every time a new firestore document is
created as you can see here I have algo
Lea on the left and firestore on the
right when new documents are added to
the database they will automatically be
updated in the index indexing operations
will always happen on the backend which
will do with nodejs and firebase cloud
functions will start from an empty
working directory and then run firebase
to net functions
I'll be using javascript for this demo
but feel free to use typescript if you
prefer that command will give us a
functions directory and you can ignore
all of the other directories that you
see on my screen for now but you can see
all of these frameworks specific
front-end integrations in the full
source code from there will CD into the
functions directory and install algo
leus search this is an API client for
node and it's going to require our API
keys which we can retrieve from the algo
Lea dashboard you'll need your
application ID as well as your admin API
key and then we have this big long
command to save the API keys in the
functions environment and the reason you
want to have these as environment
variables is if you ever have to change
the API key then you can simply reset it
in the environment without having to
redeploy your cloud functions at this
point we can open up the index.js file
and we'll start writing some code we'll
go ahead and import the algo Lea search
client and then we'll make it reference
to the app ID and the admin key that we
have in the functions environment we'll
pass those values to algo Lea search and
then we'll initialize the index by
calling and net index with the name of
our index which in this case there's
customers and now we can reference this
index in any one of our cloud functions
so we'll go ahead and start by creating
a new fire store function called add to
index which makes a reference to a fire
store document whenever a new document
is created in the customers collection
it will run the code inside of this
callback the snapshot contains the newly
created data from the fire store
document that's the data that we want to
duplicate in algo Lea - any personally
identifiable information now we can
identify a record in algo Lea with its
object ID so the object ID will be equal
to the firestore document ID and that's
how we kind of can
the two objects together on both
platforms then the final step is to
return a promise from the function which
will do with index add object with a
javascript object containing the data
and object ID and that's all there is to
it now every new customer document and
firestore will be duplicated in the algo
Lea index but this function will only
run on create and it's possible that the
data might change or might be removed in
the future so we'll set up a couple of
additional cloud functions here to
handle those requirements we'll create a
second cloud function called update
index that runs whenever the firestore
document is updated this function is
almost identical to the last one with
just some minor differences instead of
having the document snapshot we have a
change object which has the firestore
document before the change and after the
change we're only concerned about the
changes afterwards because that's what
we want to update in algo lea and we'll
do that by calling index save object to
update a single object with this new
data and lastly we'll create one
additional function called delete from
index that will run when a document is
deleted from firestore and this one is
the easiest of all we simply call index
delete object and pass it the firestore
document ID and again that's why it's
important that your al-khalil object ID
matches the firestore document ID now we
can deploy our three functions by
running in firebase deploy only
functions from the command line and then
you should see your functions in the
firebase console now at this point we
could create some dummy data manually in
the firebase console but I want to show
you a little trick to quickly see the
database with some fake dummy data we
can install faker J s in the cloud
functions environment which allows us to
generate a massive amount at fake random
data from there I've created a new file
called CJ s in the functions directory
and I'm going to import firebase admin
and then call admin initialize app now
this isn't actually a cloud function
it's just a node script that will run
from the command line in just a second
here we'll go ahead and import faker and
then we'll make it reference to
firestorm then we'll write a function
called fake it and every time this
function is called it will add a new
document to the database with all of its
data being completely random and fake
and lastly we'll create an array that
has the length of the number of
documents that we want to create in this
case 20 and then we'll go ahead and call
this function for each item in the array
now because this script is in the
functions directory it will
automatically pick up our firebase admin
potentials and that means we can simply
go to the command line call node and
point it to the script and the result
should be 20 new documents in your
database now because we've already
deployed our functions this will also
result in 20 function invocations for
the oncreate event and that means if we
refresh our algo Lea index we should see
all of the data there as well if for
whatever reason you don't see your data
in algo Lea at this point check out the
cloud function logs to see if you have
any error messages there this would also
be a good time to validate your update
and delete cloud functions if you update
some data in firestore from the console
you should see it's reflected in algo
Lea after a couple of seconds in
addition if you delete a document from
firestore you should see that the
corresponding object in algo Lea is
removed as well it looks like the
backend implementation for full text
search is working perfectly so we'll go
ahead and move on to the front-end
integration when it comes to the
front-end algo Lea provides a lot of
support for different frameworks
including angular react view iOS and
Android I'll show you the angular
implementation details in this video but
what if you're working with a framework
that's not supported likes felt in that
case you can use the API client directly
or you can use the instant search jst
let's go ahead and start by looking at
these spelt implementation details
because it's not framework specific and
could work with any framework if you
wanted to go this route first we'll go
ahead and install algo Lea search into
the app and you can also install instant
search at this point as well instant
search will give you a bunch of
pre-built widgets but in this case I'm
going to build a completely new UI from
scratch we'll go into our spelt
component and then we'll import on Mount
as well as algo Lea search and we really
only need algo Lea search light in this
case then we'll initialize properties
for the search client as well as the
index that were referencing then we'll
have the query that the user types into
the forum and then the hits that get
returned back from algo Lea with these
search results from there we initialize
the search client which is almost
identical to how we did it in the cloud
function except that we use the search
API key instead of the admin API key
it's extremely important to keep your
admin API key out of your front-end code
because it would allow anybody to modify
or completely destroy your index from
there we'll go ahead and make a
reference to the customers index and
then we can make a search by simply
calling search on that object with the
query parameters that we want to pass
in this case we'll simply be passing the
text that the user types into the form
but you could also pass additional
options here to customize the behavior
now we want to run a query every time
that user types into a form so we'll go
ahead and handle that with a function
called search it will await the results
of a query and then that result object
has a hits property which contains all
of the objects from the Algol iya index
for that search query so every time the
hits property is updated that will cause
spell to react and update the state of
the UI now moving down to the HTML we'll
go ahead and set up a text input and
then we'll bind the value of that text
input to the query property on the
component and we want to run the search
on every key up event so we'll go ahead
and say on key up and then have it fire
the search function and now it's just a
matter of looping over the hits to
display a template for each individual
result we'll set up an image with the
hit Avatar and then we'll display a
heading with a user name but you might
also want to highlight the text that the
user has typed with the results that are
returned
now Algol II returns a highlighted
result that contains the raw HTML of a
property with the text highlighted so
one way to use that data is to bind it
to the inner HTML of a paragraph element
by default it will contain the text of
that property but with the highlighted
part wrapped in an e/m element and you
can actually customize the element used
here from the Algol iya dashboard now to
make the highlight really standout we'll
go ahead and add a global style here for
the emphasis and you can see when we
type into the form in the demo that
these search results are updated and the
user's keywords are highlighted in the
search result
now this UI could obviously use a lot of
work but we now have a full stack full
text search feature in our spelt app
that was pretty easy but if you're using
angular viewer react it's even easier
algo Lia provides a bunch of pre-built
libraries and components for these
frameworks to get started with the
angular version you'll want to follow
the official setup instructions which
will have you install the package and
add it to your ng module and then I've
generated a search component here in my
angular app and you can see that it
relies on 0 typescript whatsoever and
that's because algo leah has already
done that stuff for you under the hood
so you're simply working in the template
to display the actual UI elements that
you want to show the end user the first
thing you'll do is wrap your elements in
the AIS instance search component and
that will give you the context to search
ace
civic index from there you'll want to
display a form input which you can do
with a is search box and you can use the
a is hits component to give you the
context for the hits and the actual
search result object itself and you can
use angular directives to customize the
behavior of the template for example
will say no match is found when the hits
length equals zero and then we'll go
ahead and use ng-if to loop over the
array of hits and display a template for
each result and we can easily highlight
text by using the built in a is
highlight component just specify the
attribute you want to highlight and then
pass in the hit as an input property and
now we have full stack full text search
and angular so at this point it's just a
matter of making it look good with our
design system so I'm gonna go ahead and
wrap things up there but keep in mind
there's a lot more you can do without
Golia like multi property filtering geo
queries and things like that if this
video helped you please like and
subscribe and consider becoming a pro
member at fire ship IO to get access to
even more content
thanks for watching and I will talk to
you soon
[Music]